love your enemies for they tell you your
faults
always acknowledge fault frankly
this will throw those in Authority off
guard
and give you an opportunity to make a
choice
violand
they're not making it anymore
the longer we dwell on our misfortunes
the greater is their power to harm us
an investment in knowledge
pays the best interest
always forgive your enemies
nothing annoys them so much
I think there is only one quality worse
than Hardness of Heart
and that is softness of head
a man can never have too much red wine
too many books
or too much ammunition
blessed is he that expects nothing
for he shall never be disappointed
the only way to keep your health is to
eat what you don't want
drink what you don't like and do what
you'd rather not
the reason so many people never get
anywhere in life is because when
Opportunity Knocks
they are out in the backyard looking for
four-leaf clovers
when you are asked if you can do a job
tell them
certainly I can
then get busy and find out
how to do it
rather go to bed without dinner than to
rise in debt
by failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail
whatever is begun in anger
ends in shame
if you could kick the person in the
pants responsible for most of your
trouble
you wouldn't sit for a month
keep your eyes wide open before marriage
half shut afterwards
our labor preserves us from three great
evils
weariness Vice and want
dust thou love life
then do not squander time
for that's the stuff life is made of
it is enough that people of the nation
do not understand our Banking and
monetary system
for if they did
I believe there would be a revolution
before tomorrow morning
think how difficult it is to change
yourself and you will understand how
insignificant your opportunities are to
change others
do something every day that you don't
want to do
this is the golden rule for acquiring
the habit of doing your duty without
pain
the only time you really live fully is
from 30 to 60.
the younger slaves to dreams the old
Servants of regrets
only the middle age to have all their
five senses in the keeping of their wits
lengthen thy life
lessen thy meals
you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
Whenever there is a hard job to be done
I assign it to a lazy man
he is sure to find an easy way of doing
it
the happiest of all lives is a busy
solitude
if you pick up a starving dog and make
him prosperous
you will not bite you
this is the principal difference between
a dog and a man
will do many things to get himself loved
he will do all things to get himself
envied
courage is rightly esteemed the first of
human qualities
because it is the quality which
guarantees all others
never argue with stupid people
they'll drag you down to their level
and beat you with experience
tricks and treachery of the practice of
fools
they don't have brains enough to be
honest
he that falls in love with himself will
have no rivals
the truth must be served like a coat
and not thrown in the face like a wet
towel
hide not your talents
Bay for use were made
what's a sundial in the shade
keep away from people who try to
belittle your ambitions
small people always do that but the
really great make you feel that you too
can become great
when you're finished changing you're
finished
there are many ways of going forward
but only one way of standing still
right injury is in dust
benefits in marble
associate with men of good quality if
you esteem your own reputation
for it is better to be alone
than in Bad Company
if a man empties his purse into his head
no one can take it from him
I would rather obey a fine lion much
stronger than myself
than 200 Rats of my own species
let us live so that when we come to die
even the Undertaker will be sorry
one of the greatest discoveries a man
makes
one of his great surprises is to find he
can do what he was afraid he couldn't do
actions are the seeds of fate
Deeds grow into destiny
one ought never to turn one's back on a
threatened danger and try to run away
from it
if you do that you will double the
danger
but if you meet it promptly and without
flinching
you will reduce the danger by half
never throughout history has a man who
lived a life of ease left a name worth
remembering
big jobs usually go to The Men Who prove
their ability to outgrow small ones
the greatest lesson in life is to know
that even fools are right sometimes
remember not only to say the right thing
in the right place
but far more difficult still
to leave unsaid the wrong thing at the
tempting moment
he that is good at making excuses is
seldom good at anything else
circumstances make man
not man circumstances
what we have done for ourselves alone
dies with us
what we have done for others in the
world remains and is immortal
better a broken promise than none at all
the most important single ingredient in
the formula of success is knowing how to
get along with people
grief can take care of itself
but to get the full value of a joy
you must have somebody to divide it with
it is a wise child that knows its own
father
and an unusual one that unreservedly
approves of him
if you think you can do a thing or think
you can't do a thing
you're right
there is no sadder sight than a young
pessimist
courage is what it takes to stand up and
speak
courage is also what it takes to sit
down and listen
the man who was a pessimist before 48
knows too much
if he is an optimist after it he knows
too little
whatever a man's age he can reduce it by
several years by putting a bright
colored flower in his buttonhole
life's tragedy is that we get old too
soon
and wise too late
when in doubt
tell the truth
there are 869 different forms of lying
but only one of them has been squarely
forbidden
Thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor
who have enemies
good
that means you've stood up for something
sometime in your life
it is the little conveniences that make
the real comfort of life
to be busy is man's only happiness
failure is simply the opportunity to
begin again this time more intelligently
only two things we'll regret on Deathbed
that we are a little loved and little
traveled
I'm an old man and I have known a great
many troubles
but most of them never happened
don't think money does everything
or you are going to end up doing
everything for money
never argue with a fool
onlookers may not be able to tell the
difference
when you're good to others
your best to yourself
what more valuable than gold
diamonds
then diamonds
virtue
courage is resistance to fear
Mastery of fear not absence of fear
search others for their virtues
thyself for thy vices
it is better to take many injuries than
to give one
in this world nothing could be said to
be certain
except death and taxes
there are three things extremely hard
Steel
a diamond
and to know one's self
labor to keep alive in your breast that
little spark of celestial fire
called conscience
it is the Working Man Who is the happy
man
it is the idle man who is the miserable
we lavish gifts upon children
but the most precious gift
our personal association which means so
much to them
we give grudgingly
they who can give up essential Liberty
to obtain a little temporary safety
deserve neither Liberty nor safety
he that can have patience
can have what he will
money has never made man happy
nor will it
there is nothing in its nature to
produce happiness
the more of it one has
the more one wants
don't hit it at all if it is honorably
possible to avoid hitting
but never hit soft
some people die at 25.
and aren't buried until 75.
at 20 years of age the will Reigns at
30. the wit and at 40.
the judgment
there is no man living that can do more
than he thinks he can
it is easier to prevent bad habits than
to break them
foreign
and a shadow attend only while the sun
shines
I saw a few die of hunger
of eating
a hundred thousand
he that speaks much is much mistaken
of all the Liars in the world
sometimes the worst are our own fears
the most important decision you make is
to be in a good mood
the art of medicine consists of amusing
the patient while nature cures the
disease
the only real mistake is the one from
which we learn nothing
the whole secret of a successful life is
to find out what is one's Destiny to do
and then do it
if passion drives you
let reason hold the Reigns
continuous effort not strength or
intelligence is the key to unlocking our
potential
we make a living by what we get
we make a Life by what we give
in any moment of decision the best thing
you can do is the right thing the next
best thing is the wrong thing
and the worst thing you can do
is nothing
do what you can with what you have
Where You Are